so of the most bike please note this
meeting will be audio record should we
be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the room by the
doors of the fire escape staircase
please hold both handrails case the
stairs or without slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs when they
please allow others to exit the room
before they go to the forest lake shore
where they can then be given assistance
a similar point will be in the public
car park at the size of the Civic sweet
please do not delay your evacuation
deflecting belongings and please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do some crack council
staff thank you very much right
apologies for absence and then we got
apologies from June to now major thank
you very much indeed any others non
members attending to goody welcome Julie
very welcome minutes in the meeting held
on the seventh of September
216 is it your wish I sinuses true
record it's brewed thank you any
declarations of interest please anything
arises during the meeting please declare
it then we'll make sure it goes 10
minutes item 5 matters referred to the
executive the reports from other
committees don't be there already so we
go straight to item 6 which you should
have papers for which is the government
for you Sam and other I think Simon
you're going to lead on this yes this is
an unfortunate offer quick death and I
would like to give you a variety of
choices but unfortunately we know we're
in times of austerity and in such times
and where the forecast is for a number
of variables that are beyond our
capability to prevent we predict having
good some sort of stability through a
four-year settlement is a recommended
way forward it's the way forward good
I'm led to believe about 90% plus above
the council's have signed up for so the
risk that we potentially be exposed to
if we decide you to be the odd one out
is unfortunately too much of a risk the
council I fail to undertake that there
are there are some further figures and
Rob can take you through the details
should you wish any further information
yeah I thought you get a no through the
role of everything like that and then
please x-large good see George yeah good
to see eter I'm very refreshed and so
I'm ready to get my teeth into this he
can okay I definitely through the report
and it would be I would like to actually
get your opinion on the proposals which
is being presented okay both of them
living it on Simon's well so and square
while we so we've got this is the
backside of settlement figures so this
is how much money government will give
us and equally allow us to have from the
plant so the previously as I mentioned a
few times before we had something with
the rhd the revenue support grant and
that's fundamentally how we got funding
from government 13 full team they
changed it so that we would take control
the business rates and council tax
ourselves we take on the risk of those
equal if we can grow council tax and
digitized we take a greater slice so
that was the risk-reward base in the
background what they ended was actually
start to top slice the Irish jig start
to cut it down we originally had
something like two million of this grime
in about 13 14 as of this year with our
45,000 pounds left as of next year it
will be 0 the only being is at that
point we will have no further
involvement in terms of government
Thunder so that was the sort of any idea
about it has been financially
sustainable whatever we can then
generate through council tax and
business right we be able to keep a
percentage on now there's a unique
situation as commanded and it is a its
unique situation to 20 20 20 21 onwards
where the calculation that's used for
how to work out rsg actually pushes us
into what's called a negative rsg
position which basically means we
collect more business rates than nothi
we need it's not conscious decision by
government and not sure if you're
getting too much the calculation is been
set and we've been using the same
calculation since 2013-14 but every
other council has all been doing the
same we've never had enough funding from
business right so we got enough
government have decided by 2020 the
austerity package needs to be so severe
the level of funding for all global
government has been shrunk by a
considerable amount now we're allowed a
percentage of that it's always the same
percentage we would get obviously we
were before we had a percentage of a big
slice you now we've gotten percent of a
much smaller slice what grabs you said
is the amount of money we receive in
business right is actually greater then
what the government can give us because
they need that money to give elsewhere
okay so that's where this negative r SG
is coming we are not the only ones
affected pretty much every council in
essex affected every district majority
of districts across the country are
affected it is a big issue that's been
raised the only positive we've got out
of this this negative r SG is the fact
that in twenty nineteen twenty nineteen
nineteen they are changing the business
rates system where they're talking about
well it's bins that they were introduced
107 business rates retention I'll get to
number tell me if you've got any
questions I haven't currently for
business rates we would be all something
like 60 million in lots of district take
off a few million from appeals and bits
and pieces but that's sort of the rough
figure of that we get around 1.7 1.8
million net rest of it goes off to
government majority go towards
government and Emin goes off to Essex
County Council small amount a couple of
million and a couple hundred thousand
software 65 so in terms of our take on
our business right we're looking at ten
to twenty percent Mackle attempts in the
histories with a hundred percent
business right what they're saying is
you can potentially retain 16 million
but an element of it will still have to
be given back to government so they can
fund some of the or Never Cyprus on the
northern areas that don't have enough
business to fund so an element will
always have to go back so so we ended up
with maybe 10 million of business rate
compared to the one point I'd we get now
they said you can have that 10 million
that's entirely in your gift but we're
not going to do is just give you ten
million because that would never work
physical across the whole country when
we work so they've then got give us
additional responsibilities and it's
these responsibilities they're currently
deciding on what we can get so we might
get nine million pounds worth of pieces
of work such for a ten million pounds
business rights therefore we're in the
money of course we never did that but we
have no idea yet that could be the other
way they could get was 12 million pounds
worth of work and only out of 10 million
and funding this is the whole
consultation that's going on at the
month so the only thing we've got on
this negative IRS years it will be
wrapped up in the business wrote
hundreds of business rates of attention
but I'm not going to say that that's
going to wash it out completely because
we just don't know no one can tell us
yet they done that they're still working
like there's two consultations out of
the market model so it's very much if we
didn't have this negative rsg I'd be
saying guys by their handle absolutely
by the hand of get a four-year 719 will
be going to be spending in four years
time whole hardly and the numbers done
look bad there's this negative virus
gene is 653 2000 sting in the towel in
2020 that's really for the captain
Monday pigeons I'm wife until we my
counterpart talking on the phone to my
counterparts for the last few weeks so
in chelmsford and castle point
particularly as affected as us they've
both been given delegated authority by
their cabinet to make the decision but
they're telling me in mind they're both
they're both counter into it the LGA
about several conversations with this is
from Chelmsford and they have told him
as well accept the deal this is not
going to get any better and if you're in
one of the districts are one of the
council's that haven't signed up to the
settlement any further cuts are all
coming your way they're not going to
reward you for it so to prove son of may
I please so if we signed up right now if
they do present us with cuts going
forward they won't Rep respectively I
impose those at those cuts they told us
they want I'm never going to start
hundred percent because this is central
government camera nail on things but
they're telling us the four years
everyone is the four-year settlement bar
any mass drastic changes like business
rates for tenders so that would be there
get out i would say for us my my gut
feel is before your settlement is more
like a guaranteed three-year settlement
and then the fourth year is very much up
in year depending what happens or
everything else so when we win would we
want to make a decision well tonight
tonight I need a decision tonight all
the other way so your s your decision is
you can delegate it to me and I can
decide on the evening other 13th I have
to submit by the 14th either way now i'm
pretty sure it's on into position yeah
it is a rock and a hard place it is on
foot i'm not gonna like as a gamble i
think the odds are stacked in the house
is valueless are fancy going against the
tripod imagine ninety percent of
counselors who signed up to this if they
suddenly find out that those that hadn't
signed are actually better off I think
there will be
we both coming full swing frankly if we
look into those little figures for those
that do sign we've done on your cap
excuse me territorial county councils
done have negative obviously that's how
your big hitters already camera sign up
to this yeah okay any other points
please it's mine it's just an
observation realistically in the part of
the negative to me this seems as if the
government is allowing itself quite a
large measure of lean like going forward
so it's even unsure of its position in
that fourth year so it's allowing itself
sufficiently one to be able to look at
the position going forward so even
though we're set but we're going for the
settlement you know I try to want to
look at this in a more optimistic like
rather than in another way in saying
that we don't know the benefits that are
going to accrue from brexit as we go
forward which shall we go into unknown
territory with everything that's going
on there obviously stacking their own
odds so that they can actually call back
money legally from us if necessary if
necessary so you know if there is better
productivity as we go forward this
negative element may not occur so you
know I mean it's a gamble of both but I
can understand the government's view
that they're giving us a hundred percent
but they want to make sure that that
distribution nationally is in their gift
rather than not but i think i think it's
worth taking a chance especially if we
get you know a far better economy going
forward okay thanks Ian they chairman
I'm not I'd take on what inside I'm not
really interesting what the government's
problems are
30 more this district yeah you're right
as well and I think as we discussed the
design myself I think we all have
serious concerns about this yeah we were
effectively signing up and deal where we
could potentially lose money but we we
have no room or other other alternative
that's the that is the problem I don't
think any of us are particularly
comfortable with with what we're going
to be enforced to sign up for but that
is is the reality if it's any
consolation I guess politically you know
as Rob's already see if ninety percent
the counters all going to be in the same
is their sale at our answer will ninety
percent of us all I've been crucified
effectively as opposed to being temper
sent but I think any I mean I don't
think to be honest this match
alternative other than to sign up for it
but you know as an individual or
personally I'm not at all comfortable
with them the whole situation brutal yet
sure you want to do two things Christian
family Amina myself I suppose what I'm
hearing and not surprisingly is is is
that members reluctantly are likely to
want to agree site to sign up the
numbers of the word reluctantly I think
is the key word and that being the case
it does it does seem to me that there's
merit than making our views and concerns
Nolan to the minister as part of the
submission so we may very well
reluctantly sign up but but actually
explaining our position and concerns
about it I think would be would be
justified may not do any good they may
not be listening but at least we we put
on record
the you know the concerns of the council
has with the situation that we find
ourselves in the same the second point
James just a practical standpoint I've
got the copy of the I don't think I've
circulated previously but I know you
have a copy of a business the business
rates presentation that the you heard
the last because it's actively there's
only 18 yep that's right and that was
presenting I am markedly in the evening
Johnson and I think it really useful
without it I various circulate that to
all members because it's got some very
listed and good explanation of how the
business works and what time table is
for the phonetic for the new system just
as that's that all members yes yes
Oliver get a membership so I'll lick
very interested circulate that and if
you've got any questions you know that
come back to Toronto I think there's
plenty of unknowns there as well so you
know that's dad's the period isn't it
but at least disclosing information
about what time to however listen what
time to you as far as we know yeah it's
interesting when you look at this
because politics have sort of go
sideways over the recent months through
the voting June with a changing Prime
Minister with a new chancellor
particular virtually a new cabinet
completely and and the where we stand in
the world the form of the value of staff
sterling the rise in the stock exchange
you know things are very volatile at the
moment and I think one of the things we
can't predict is where and home day you
said about you know you don't look so
worried about government but the trouble
is where we get our funding from some of
it comes from government and if they're
in in the lawyer then we might be
putting them are as well and that's the
problem really that we stay but I think
as far as our local area is concerned I
mean we've got the the airport which
pays us money bar business rates we've
got development
being on the new business part which
hopefully will increase our business
rates we've got development going on in
the district as well which helps so you
know we're not in a tube and a position
as Rochford you know sitting where we
sit but having said that who knows what
the future is but that's the very thing
chairman yeah our funding from
government is stopping yeah it's the
very essence is also called today giving
you on a funding bill didn't world but
usually with these things what the right
hand give the left hand takes that's all
right you know and that's that's the way
it's always been unfortunately but to
some dance like no sign an army happy to
endorse frog or Shana adding the
comments about are opting for situations
where as a council we should try and see
the positive in this as you've just
outlined there's a number of things
going on in the district the district
snotting talk about a position we've got
a medium term financial strategy on that
Saturday we spend some time as a council
all members thinking about where where
we can go out how we can go forward
project we might get involved in we know
that we've got a big funding gap moving
forward whatever the settlement this
this arrangement gives us an amount of
stability might not be nice ability but
it it gives us a mout an amount of
stability it then allows us to move
forward planning on the gap and how we
can close it we would not be able to
deliver any of our ambitions if on a
year-by-year basis we had to stop review
what staffing we could cope we can cope
with whether we'd have to have
redundancies review what services we
might or not might not have in a
particular we wouldn't have the capacity
to take this council forward so I
thought that that is the only positive
that I can see in this but having the
stability for our financial planning is
something that
it's just picking up the other side of
the coin do you take the child's not
sign up and you freelance it basically
and then I take it you end up with
having to to fund a deficit of which
your you have is a no none so i guess if
if other councils have signed up and
there's a gap you will be asked to find
that gap however big it is and that
could actually drop you into the most
dreadful financial state because of the
fact that you haven't actually signed up
to it so I guess that that is the bigger
risk I guess the other thing is cool
stability just you know more or less
we've got my tell me obviously the
appointment as I said before if we took
the negative rst point athletes this is
a good something you really we would
just sign out in four years seven
o'clock side the certainty certain the
up next virus t-mike's obviously its
impact in four years time the fact is if
we don't sign up for this now next year
settlement son knows and that's that's
where the risks of is not just a risk in
four years time the risk could be very
much within three months six months view
and that's where we didn't have to try
and turn it around extremely quickly to
up to a very unknown difference that's a
you know and I do appreciate I'm not
going to say this easy is a is a gamble
we do obviously have we've still got a
business rate consultation which I have
a quick draft attack as pages response
outlining this is an issue so and we
need this review is part of a fear of
funding model and we're also going to
that's going to go by the 29th October
pasta around and there's also a piece of
work I'm doing this week for a
representation in the autumn statement
where I again I'm going to go back with
some options to governments they
actually you can get rid of negative
iris gene by things like redistributed
some of the business Rachel metropolitan
areas to the more room to the more
County Shire based areas where actually
a lot of the workers coming from Reuben
so they're force of redistribution more
I'm coming up in two so it gives them
not just you need to give us more money
it's the reasons why they need to give
us one that's hopefully that one isn't
so big about that will be going friday
so thank you is that right good
mentioned that government is likely to
push things our way absolutely yeah yeah
it hasn't been any speculations what
there's like 30 we like having to pick
up health issues website it could be
said of certain moments that the major
barriers that could be considered the
skills the skills budget which is a
billion across the country serve 16 plus
type schools funding college funding
things like that could come to us where
am i part 2 by the public health love
grant at my breakfast in our area 50 min
ago to Essex County Council that could
come directly into the district parishes
County with no funding but we have to
fund public health it's those sorts of
types of things I've relax a there's a
consultation at the moment where it's
basically anyone come up with some ideas
and that's it but there the laser pick
to at the moment and it obviously don't
know any further economic growth the
type of investments so the king you just
don't know we don't sourcing it if you
imagine check where everyone's on this
two different sites we've got local
authorities wherever you're from sign
we'll take that one we'll take that one
with it because we know we can play
around with the fingers fight here maybe
we now did an equally central government
the other side come on how you have that
one that one and that one which is
really what the risk they want parts
over so excited there's a lot of
negotiation going on that weekend let's
just ask through you I mean the Essex
finest officers I know you have meetings
and you're you know a greaser and things
and to give you information I mean
Jubilee this is something you're all
very much program trading on so if there
was something in the wind or going on
chances are you'll get to hear be very
very soon so you can't do that you know
promise if you like if you do hear
something so these members need to know
as soon as they can absolutely but you
know this is this is being offered or
not offered or you know going forward
because I think that's how we need to
consider it into the future but what I
want in any business in any market what
you don't want is that volatility that
affects everything so the sooner you
know about these things the sooner you
can react to it so if I make a
suggestion because because the other
thing we can do we still have like two
that the fittest about eight date and
world could change no dice so my
suggestion could potentially be you
agree in principle it's a sign up to it
tonight and intensely delegate it down
to myself and to yourself chair and we
have a discussion on the 13th inside the
welder hasn't changed things haven't
changed yam Seng any further movement we
also get some Intel from anywhere else
and if it looks like there's a
fundamental difference we'll make that
decision if not we just reconnected we
could add the line subject to
confirmation with the 151 on soon
conjunction with the leader yeah don't
if members are happy they're not a lot
like some Z's yeah take that forward
given so and what are you lose something
possible I mean I Rob made a very good
suggestion in as much as that he wants
to put in proposals that would be coming
from us and I guess would be the same
for most councils with regard to you
know alternatives how how you envisage
changed where you're actually showing
that a lot of the people who actually
live here are working in London and
suchlike and you know where that economy
is and where some of that metropolitan
money should actually be diverted a wee
bit out to here if we can see those
arguments I would be very much obliged
to see exactly how you're going to fry
now let's close it on I think
traditionally young
remember back to my e reduce that's
going back a bit now traditionally the
eastern England got the lowest
settlement of any area and I think we're
still in that position and I think
London gets quite quite a bit more per
head that we certainly do in the in the
shower destroy guessing you know
ourselves included of course if you look
at the table for rate support Graham
unfortunately right or district
councillors the top of being taught
means we actually lose more than all the
others as a percentage which is not a
good place to me so you know but we
don't win on any count really
unfortunately and yet we've still got
provide services and take ourselves
forward so it's it's a difficult
position we're in absolute but again
part of what you're talking about you
know the politically the Essex finance
officers will no doubt acts as a body to
recommend to their various councils
including hopefully the two unitary and
the county council that these are the
suggestions that we're bringing forward
and if we can act as one voice I think
that makes it that much stronger so even
on a regional basis and there's no I
think there are regional I think reason
we to start come up to November but
nevertheless things like a member of
that that then find something if we can
get that in one voice I think that makes
a lot so members you've heard about the
amendment sorry to march of the easy
answer i'm just a couple of observations
firstly it may be appropriate for it to
be the second one 51 officer in
consultation with a leader and the
portfolio helluva fine and yes justice
and secondly now you're going up to a
certain wire you need really a
resolution to include that it's not
subject to calling either you can make
on which is that would be appropriate
with this decision yes but the minute
also needs to bring where Cecilia
watching yeah okay happy with all that
members area yeah so we will breathe
Israel and I thank you look for that I
think that's very intelligent way for
they're taking it forward and fits the
circumstances I'm not so difficult
decision but thank you right moving on
I'll get the price for your chosen the
next one is the about the consultation
so if I can ask you that you're going to
use this very short and sweet love
people and lovely house tax deduction
still there were legal requirements
carry out consultation transportation on
your starts this monday come in the 10
and will run until the cylinder nothing
but something we have to do this is just
the other station of asking
consultation dongjun into London even
found yep chairman and say the
consultation will run from the 7th at
the 10 to the seventh november and in
the documentation consultation we do put
everything in there that is proposed
that we can for it to the local
transportation screen changes and we're
not writing to implement any of them but
this obviously we are legally and
illegally have to go out to console
public consultation the transportation
will be going out onto our website
published on there and aunt around
reloading through the habit of your
sacred we also advise the c a b and
other partner associations as well in
the past the results of the public
consultation haven't been that great so
you know it comes back for a decision
and it
in December where we've done an equality
impact assessment on any of these and
the results of the consultation from
there and then it will be down for a
decision for members to decide whether
we want to adopt any of these changes
okay does that come on account for hall
council isn't it at full council yeah so
here we are members were talking about
the actual consultation free through the
consultation it all seems person and
very simple the only thing I was going
to say to you is you're going out on the
website other any other is to try to
reach those people so many of the people
we're trying to reach on this I'm not
traditionally people you would reply to
something like this as wonder if we're
taking any measures to try and reach
those people yeah we m-maybe we would
have put it into butcher district
matters which obviously was a right
before you need yeah and so we are
actively sated with the CIA be it will
be with them for them collaborative
paper format for them to consult well as
I say it's difficult for us to get
results back and you know they only what
two decisions on system sciences I use
taken out with like parish councils yes
Housing Association groups and all those
types of urges there it there advised as
well okay thank you for hearing inside
yeah I mean as you probably know we are
involved in the survey at this moment
which in some cases has been most savage
because we are not as thorough as they
believe we are and we're not contacting
as many people as they believe we should
be and again that's a concern i have
with the consultations that are going
out you know again about what is to sort
of come back where you haven't consulted
enough you haven't gone through every
hoop that we actually set up and i
figure out the park theatre just
bringing comes the diced variable this
this was something that again we put
through didn't weigh on how we consult
yeah and you know i think i think it's
extremely difficult games on the various
parts you know to what to like it as
thorough as we can I mean we're giving
it as bigger effort as we can and I'm
sure that you will as well but it is a
concern do yet but Summers face the
ninja
hearing that a variety different is
going to be engaged I think is
particularly important because some of
the people this is going to affect
potentially on those that can access a
lot of services and just reading through
the text it there's an amount of it that
that doesn't make itself very easily
understood if you've got any any issues
the the results I suspect might be a bit
slanted because it talks about
reductions in the council tax reduction
scheme so I think we do have to be aware
of the the slanting that the results
might have although I'm not prejudging
get it any opinion the morn formed long
do seen razones thinking too much yes um
something which the parachute vice chair
is actually contacted me and asked me
it's only parry establish parity with
regards to this there they want to know
from a cost perspective how parishes can
actually mitigate their costs in source
circulating this material to the around
the parachutes of such something which
I'd like to good question
I don't know the answer to that into the
parishes I think it is just still down
to the parachute yeah there you go but
the only other thing I'd say is that
clearly you can you can post there some
communities going to faces like
libraries those for public places that
are out there so you know that you know
it is out there so that's hope that
people respond to it presumably we're
not the only council that's going to put
this out as well so they'll be like
their national picture going forward
sorry tell you ginger just recopy
temperature and I think the general
issue of Constitution engagement
favorite oh listen it's only when when
our new website is is launched fairly
imminently now we've added a new
facility to it called Gulf delivery
which you may be familiar with because
it's actually only its kind gentle
website in fact and what it is it's a
it's a mechanism for getting resistance
to actually sign up for information to
come from that from the council so we
are the idea is that you register
there'll be a flag on the new website
you can click it register and you can
then indicate the sort of information
that you want to want to receive in a
tailored way and over a period of time
hopefully we'll get to situation where
we're able to engage on different types
of consultation with significant
proportions of the of the residents in
the district in a way that is it's not
so
not so easy now so that's something that
we've gotten a new website hopefully it
will give us a new dimension to the way
that we can engage with residents go
clear good at one point if I came
through your door I've had lots of
consultation things through if you
actually try and use an iPad for some of
these things is quite critical do you
know if this is ipad friendly I can it's
one of those things that some reason
even when you go on to things like
Windows you can usually to interact with
the document with an iPad because it's a
live system you know it's a Apple it's
not so easy that's just arming
presumably also if you've got a lot of
people might just respond with your
mobile and so am i again it might be an
apple one or it might just be a android
run or even windows one I things with
those ones then aren't they so you know
it's it's a you know I just wonder if
we're talking to our I they're sort of
computer boards to see if that's that's
the case was there having to stop people
responding on you know not necessarily
that we're following the thing but
actually responding in words if you like
so at least we know what their answers
are but it doesn't mean you've got to
transpose stuff would have an
opportunity to do that you ever make
sure that it is on our way in a format
that can be used
different devices yeah if you could do
that at my brother so for chairman ever
what what's like happen is that is that
probably on this consultation we may
very well be overlapping the old website
with a new website the new website is it
is designed to be brilliant on any any
any sort of device which is not
something you can necessarily see about
the current website so all the well
actually there's a new stuff coming they
do another launch date for that and it
is its recent asset imminent was because
it is a minute but it exactly the actual
days it's actually dependent or not
we're just doing a bit of work on this
on this gov delivery mechanism because
we want that to be embedded within the
new website before we launch it so it's
probably within the next next couple of
the camera but as soon as I've got
pssshew easier yep storage and meeting
an expression that's good all know it's
my I please i have i've seen the beta
version and i've played around with it
and also i took my head off to our
officers who and dawn and and sean
who've managed this i think it's it's
going to benefit the council it looks
the ticket it does yeah so i'll be the
test of these things i'm always told you
these two clinks to anything exactly i'm
sure members will ever play when we get
our new site is there any opportunity
for us to have an early look as a beta
version chetori okay thank you thank you
sign for you because we got chinese e
training time so this probably progress
or originally inside okay but it might
be as well to advise members on our sort
of member member newsletter that's
imminent we were
I've got to do a catch up with so many
house okay special thank you don't any
other comments please so as far as the
consultation is concerned that if we
agree with the decision being
recommending the one by one more point
to is that really also relations
department not put something out in the
first place so it should show a computer
icons department could I not come market
chairman and I just made a note that
actually the great ones i grew up quick
communication than make you six we have
got much district matters now which is
what we would have yeah pacific ocean
anybody causing the local papers but
then again I think the circulation of
the local papers gone down considerably
and i only get the yellow advertiser in
in a computer for now which they said to
me which is good that at least is
something yeah that's you so I mean we
can put all its concentration that mean
yeah the meeting last night I'm coming
you have five members of the public turn
up and I counselors absolute diculous
you know we can only try exactly okay so
going back there members on it I members
agree with the recommendation very major
emergency so that means the meeting
thank you so much